pretty obvious at this point that the
big legacy media organizations aren't
actually news organizations they're
partisan political operations but still
at least on paper these organizations
have rules they're supposed to follow
rules like news executives can't donate
to political campaigns that would be
improper it'd be an obvious
evidence of bias so it's not allowed
but it happens and this shows just
obtained emails demonstrating that in
private news executives don't care about
the rules or the concept of impartiality
they'll donate to any candidate they
want they just want to make certain you
don't find out about it the emails came
to us from a source with access to
hundred biden's laptop the one he left
at the computer repair shop supposedly
not sure we believe that story but the
laptop itself is absolutely real and
these documents show that a cnbc
executive used his wife to dodge company
rules that bar financial contributions
to political campaigns
in 2015 breitbart first reported the
wife of a man called brian steele who
until recently was an executive vice
president at cnbc was a hillary clinton
donor a big hillary clinton donor that
report came to light after a cnbc
republican debate that featured several
biased questions favoring democrats it
was pretty over the top actually it's on
youtube treat yourself sometime
but the emails from hunter biden's
laptop show that brian steele's wife was
spending that money at his direction
which we think is illegal actually we'll
leave that to the lawyers to determine
but here are the facts
in september 2016 hunter biden emailed
steele to invite him to a fundraiser for
a former biden aide who was running for
congress in south carolina the candidate
was called francis fran person
steele responded this way i'd love to
support fran but unfortunately as the
executive vice president of cnbc i'm not
allowed to donate to political campaigns
in years past i would get around that by
having my wife donate but after cnbc
hosted a controversial
aggressive republican primary debate
earlier this year breitbart and rush
limbaugh outed me as the husband of a
max hillary donor so i can't have eileen
donate anymore
explicit anyone
steele was at cnbc from 2007 to just
recently a month or so ago 2021.
during that time his wife donated 16 000
to democrats how much of that money was
given in his direction
we've reached out to steele and to cnbc
for comment and other one has gotten
back to us not surprisingly
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else